[Music]
when do you think that this flying taxi
will carry paying passengers five years
ten years Beyond well if you ask its
maker volocopter it could be way sooner
this is happening now next year we fly
yep the startup says they plan to Ferry
passengers during the Paris 2024 Olympic
games using their velocity aircraft so
does this mean that commercial air taxis
are finally here or will they disappear
as quickly as they arrived let's find
out
[Music]
okay so if you haven't heard that this
thing was taking off then well you
weren't alone when velocity flew here at
the air show it was so quiet some people
didn't realize it was Airborne you will
see it but you will not hear it I think
a lot of people missed it yesterday
because they didn't hear our vehicle
that's volocopter CEO Dirk hooker
speaking at the announcement of the
roots that the company intends to fly we
will start with five aircraft we will
fly every vehicle two flights per hour
times five so it brings us to run
80 to 100 flights a day the idea is to
use these electric vertical takeoff and
Landing aircraft or EV toll to connect
five popular hubs around Paris during
the games like airports to other
airports or train station if they get
airborne they might not be alone as
fellow EV tall manufacturer autoflight
have also announced that they intend to
operate during the Paris Olympics so
does this mean that you and your friends
will be whizzing from sport to sport
during next year's games well you might
have to go one at a time as the aircraft
only holds one passenger we would love
to go directly to four five six seven
seater but we also have to be realistic
on the speed of the development of
Battery Technology then there's how much
each flight would cost which seems to be
a work in progress how much is it going
to cost the last one I cannot answer you
because we didn't agree with our
partners yet we're still in discussion
volocops told me that they're eventually
aiming for tickets to cost three to four
Euros per passenger per kilometer but
they said to me that that was very
aspirational and would require an
aircraft that could carry more
passengers for now they plan on offering
subsidized tickets if you combine the
potentially High ticket price with the
single seat occupancy and the fact that
there will only be a couple of these
these things flying each hour then it
means that volocopter's flights during
the Olympic Games could be less of an
efficient commuter route and more of a
niche tourist experience for those at
the games can we replace a bus can we
replace the Metro System no it's not
even the attention we want to add
another option and this is all if the
company gets to Paris by the Olympic
Games at all as their flights will be on
the condition that their aircraft
receives certification in time and
that's a big if we said we plan and we
aim for we strive for it because I
cannot guarantee that that we're already
ready because we are having a very very
challenging certification time plan so
does that mean that volocopter is more
of a tourist experience than a Bonafide
air taxi for now maybe but that doesn't
mean it always will be see there are a
lot of EV toll startups trying to get
their aircraft off the ground and
they're all going to have to start
somewhere United has said it's working
with Embers Eve to bring its air taxi to
San Francisco and Evie told startup
Archer has said it hopes to be operating
during the LA Olympic Games in 2028 and
even if volocopter doesn't make the
Paris Olympic Games Dirk told me that he
hopes the company will still be flying
long after the games have departed we
need to see how the public reacts but
overall now we want to go 24 months and
Beyond so next time you're in Paris make
sure to look up there could be a very
quiet taxi with one passenger making its
way through the skies
[Music]
foreign